all right of the three franchises that
Blizzard has and does while Diablo is
one of them and after over a decade we
finally have Diablo 3 so let's review it
this one's better late than ever kind of
things
Diablo 3 and if you don't know what
Diablo 3 is it's okay that means you
don't PCE game Diablo 3 like Diablo 1 2
is a point-and-click hack-and-slash type
game and judging by the name you can
pretty much figure out that it has to do
with evil rising and taking over and
people who have to stop it now in Diablo
3 you can pick one of five different
classes a monk a demon hunter a wizard a
witch doctor and a barbarian and the
cool thing I love about Diablo 3 is that
all the characters are completely badass
the one that has the slowest start to
him is the wizard I just noticed by like
you know level 5 other characters are
just stomping everything the wizard has
a slower build up but when you kill
something they just die epically
everything is always all these
combustion to flame you're like whoo
that happened and I did that and in the
world if you're not going to please
everyone all of the time there are
people who have some gripes about Diablo
3 and how it's set up as opposed to how
its set up and - it is said that this
one feels more like World of Warcraft my
guy to say when you're looking at it
does have that World of Warcraft vibe
doesn't play like an MMO but it does
have MMO elements in it but I personally
dug it in a world where mmo's just a
dime a dozen there's a zillion of those
things out there I had more fun with
Diablo 3 than any MMO lately it's one of
these games you go to bed and you just
think about then you wake up and you log
on you just play it so what's so great
about it what makes the replay value so
huge first of all the randomized
dungeons when you play through the game
a couple times you like it feels like
it's the same and the overall area is
going to be generally speaking the same
but it's just structured differently
like someone shuffled around a puzzle
and you can run into different things
different scenarios I was playing the
game in this big field this farmers like
she's freaking out because demons are
ravaging his farm and I had to go save
his farm because when you're a witch
doctor who conjures the undead to rise
and fight for you as the kind of guy who
saves farmers farms but then I was
playing with my friends and that scene
wasn't there there was another side
dungeon that we got to do and I like the
fact that Diablo 3 structured that way
it was always a thing in the other
Diablos it was a big deal that
randomized dungeons in a game that's
made for you to play through a few
different times with the same character
randomized dungeon structures pretty
much a must my gripe about the game is
that really it's too easy your first
time through my friend and I just went
through and we just murdered everything
it's kind of a bummer I don't like games
to be that easy but then when you beat
the game you unlock hard mode and I'd
heard that I thought it was going to be
alright you unlock hard mode for
everybody but it's just your guy rock
fours the end of the game then you start
over the game in act 1
in the enemies in act 1 are levelled
pretty much how the enemies in act 5
would be if there wasn't act 5 you see
what I mean oh yeah you got me the heart
of the difficulty the enemies start
dropping better Lu you can train your
craftsmen to make better stuff and I
like this about the crafting I am NOT a
fan of crafting in games I hate crafting
I'll just go to the auction house and
buy something it's like oh do I want to
burn away hours of time training this
guy to crafts or do I want to dump a
couple thousand fake gold that I got
playing the game and just buy the gear
that I would be able to make Yap at the
least resistance let's just buy the
shit's but in Diablo 3 when you train
crafters use pay more like boom alright
now you're smarter because I paid you
money make sense I guess but you train
the guy when you train your crafter with
one character the training crosses over
to the other characters you have I like
that I love the fact that you don't have
to retrain the guy who's only in
different times same goes with your gear
say you're playing a witch doctor you're
like I don't use this helmet of might
but my barbarian will just put it in the
chest you pick up your barbarian
character and you go to the chest you
take out your helmet you wear it now I
like the fact that everything is
interchangeable like that and
jewelcrafting is cool you know when
you're you have jewels it's like Oh
gives you a plus 14 intelligence or
something you put that in a piece of
armor let's say you want to change it
out for something most games have it to
where it's like oh you want to change it
out sorry you have to destroy your armor
I'm just throwing this out there if a
jeweler cannot pull a jewel out of a
piece of armor without destroying it
they should not be a licensed jeweler I
don't care what universe world or game
we're dealing with there that person is
officially the worst jeweler of all time
but on this one you pull the jewel out
you can tweak it a little bit put it
back in change it out with another jewel
you just have to pay the jeweler a few
hundred bucks I like that it's no big
deal people feel like it's been dumbed
down they're like oh the interface has
totally been dumbed down crafting is
easy jeweling is easy even picking your
skills is easy I like the fact that it's
been simplified the interface with
civilization 5 versus civilization for
the game was still fun and involved you
just didn't have to micromanage
everything that's what I felt like they
did in Diablo 3 and if you saw my
civilization 5 review you know I'm a fan
of that kind of thing I'll say this
about the auction house there is an
auction house in Diablo 3 and you can go
there and for not a lot of money you can
buy gear that completely breaks the game
I'm saying and your first run-through
don't do that because I did that I
bought like three pieces of gear that
just stomped everything I'm like oh
sweet I'm a complete badass then you go
through and you're like everything's too
easy yeah maybe that's why the game is
too easy my first run-through when you
get into the harder difficulties
do it then but for your first
run-through don't don't go to the
auction house and they have a couple
different features that are coming out
that are not out quite yet one of which
is an auction house to take taxable
money I want to see how that works
because I personally am NOT going to
drop real money on fake gear especially
when for a few thousand gold which is
pretty easy to come across in this game
you can buy some really disgustingly
broken gear what would I need to buy
with real money that I couldn't get with
fake money I want to see that I want to
see how that works or it was just gonna
be like one dollar and there you get
gear another thing you're coming out
with for Diablo 3 is a PvP mode
maybe that's we're paying real money for
fake gear is gonna pay off in a game
escalation you know everyone's gonna
want the best gear so it's like oh you
want the best gear I'm the guy in the
game who has it so you know pay me ten
dollars in summary I will say it like
this there are two types of nostalgic
games in the world games are like this
game feels like I'm playing old-school
games in the 90s and it's completely
outdated why on earth did I buy the new
Duke Nukem game yeah bad call that's
some outdated [ __ ] right there and games
like Diablo 3 which harken back to the
PC game and point-and-click hack and
slash games and they do it well it pays
homage and it's relevant
I really can't ask for more than that in
the game in a world where shooters have
become so huge in the world of gaming
it's really cool to see a game like this
there are an array of games like this
out there but I would just say it's
refreshing a bazooka is just not quite
as cool as conjuring up a skull that
vomits acid on a group of demons that's
just absurdly entertaining right there
this is fun to play with your friends my
friend and I got potato chips and some
monster energy drinks we were did we
merit on dit man we were there for hours
it would beat the game and I can't wait
to play through the game again even with
the same character I want to see how
hard this game gets and for me to be
excited playing through a game again
with the exact same character that's a
big deal cuz I don't get excited about
that however if you do want a really
unique challenge there is hardcore mode
which is a mode where you create your
character you play the game and if you
die you don't get resurrected your
character is dead yeah no coming back he
died in his campaign he dies in the
world and I guess that's really cool I
can't wait to play that mode that's just
a level of intensity I'll just look at
my friend of you like you want to you
want to play Diablo I feel like I'm
really going to demon war here cuz I
don't I don't want to die I can't say
I've really felt that kind of anxiety in
a game how many times are you like I'll
just die and respawn here makes it
easier yeah not in hardcore mode
oblah three so have fun with that do you
need to play Diablo one and two to have
fun with this game it doesn't hurt but
you don't need to play the other two
however if you have played the other
Diablos you're gonna notice characters
you're gonna have a little more fun you
can notice things that other people
wouldn't notice so if you played Diablo
3 what did you think of it if you're not
a PC gamer are you gonna give it a shot
do you like the point-and-click hack and
slash magic and demons and fire and
death you know the fun things in life
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more